i
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe hablamos de la cepal estimado que
la pandemia de kobe 19 generó un
retroceso de más de una década en los
niveles de participación laboral de las
mujeres en la región y si le parece
vamos a comenzar viendo cifras que
ilustran a la desigualdad a la que
estamos haciendo referencia este gráfico
muestra que la tasa de desempleo de las
mujeres en 2019 era de 9.6 por ciento y
después de la pandemia es del 12%
mientras que las de los hombres eran del
7% antes de la crisis sanitaria y luego
pasó al 9.7 por ciento
y para analizar en esta información nos
acompaña alicia bárcena ella es
directora de la cepal alicia bárcena
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24
muchas gracias muy feliz de estar con
ustedes como no ha lesión y bueno es una
de las primeras dudas que surgen o como
decíamos la cepal concluye en este
estudio reciente que dijo 19 genera un
retroceso de más de una década en los
niveles de participación laboral de las
mujeres en américa latina y el caribe
cómo se llegó a esta situación aquí le
atribuye usted claro que sí con mucho
gusto precisamente o sea se redujo la
tasa de participación laboral seis
puntos porcentuales se proyecta que
hacia el final de 2020 cerró en 46 por
ciento para toda la región
y efectivamente tú hablabas de la cifra
de desocupación del 12% pero si las
mujeres estuvieran buscando trabajo la
tasa de participación laboral fuera
similar al 2019 esta cifra sería de 22
2% hay una hay una fuerte contundente
salida de las mujeres de la fuerza
laboral por las demandas de cuidado que
no han vuelto a buscar empleo después de
esta salida y esto se debe en gran
medida al cierre de muchas actividades
económicas la caída de ingresos de
muchos hogares que incidieron en una
marcada caída en el nivel de ocupación
en todos los países la verdad es que la
pérdida masiva de puestos de trabajo se
dio entre los trabajadores informales en
donde las mujeres están
sobrerrepresentadas además de estar
insertas en sectores
económicos de mayor riesgo como el
comercio la manufactura el turismo y el
trabajo doméstico remunerado y esto es
esto es muy fuerte la verdad porque en
verdad han sido sectores muy afectados
especialmente el comercio que es donde
más participan las mujeres pero también
la manufactura verdad en países sobre
todo donde en centroamérica por ejemplo
es un sector muy importante el
manufacturero de maquila en donde
estamos viendo que el empleo femenino es
alrededor del 13,2 y tuvo realmente
cierres de industrias que han provocado
una disrupción en la trayectoria laboral
de las mujeres y el otro sector que
quisiera solo destacar es el de
alojamiento y servicios asociados al
turismo es altamente feminizado en la
región hay un 61 5 por ciento de los
puestos de trabajo ocupados por mujeres
en 2019 y estamos viendo que este sector
turismo por ejemplo en el caribe
definitivamente la caída fue brutal
y por supuesto muchas mujeres quedaron
fuera del mercado laboral así es de que
efectivamente no sólo en términos de
empleo sino en términos de ingresos
familiares vemos un retroceso de 10 años
habíamos logrado mucho en un momento
dado y hoy estamos nuevamente en una
década perdida ahora otro sector
elaborar en el que las mujeres tienen
una gran presencia en el sector de la
salud no cerca del 70% de los
trabajadores de este sector son mujeres
y el estudio concluye que están en una
situación mucho más precaria que los
hombres precisamente en este sector de
la salud que ahora se encuentran o en un
contexto de crisis enorme porque esto
alicia
bueno efectivamente las mujeres forman
una parte crucial están en la primera
línea de respuesta a la pandemia 73 2%
de las personas empleadas en el sector
salud son mujeres pero ganan menos que
los hombres y este es un tema muy de
fondo ganan 23.7 por ciento en la brecha
salarial entre hombres y mujeres en un
empleo similar de iguales calificaciones
de igual yo diría este riesgo y
intensidad las mujeres están por debajo
y realmente este es un tema que se debe
abordar sí o sí porque hay una
diferencia salarial muy fuerte muy
importante que los países tienen que
vigilar porque porque no es justo en
realidad cuando las mujeres están
haciendo el mismo tipo de empleo y
tienen una brecha salarial de este
tamaño tan fuerte es diferente de
acuerdo a los distintos países tenemos
por supuesto que la brecha salarial
como te decía en promedios de 23,7 por
ciento pero hay países donde esta brecha
es incluso mayor como el caso de panamá
es de 30
29 en el caso de brasil 27 3 en cambio
hay otros casos en donde la brecha es
menor
curiosamente el salvador la brecha es de
15 la diferencia salarial o en república
dominicana es 0,5 muy interesante como
hay algunos países donde han logrado
cerrar esta brecha salarial y otros
donde realmente no se ha logrado pero en
general te diría 73 2% son las mujeres
en este sector salud por ejemplo en
república dominicana son 82 por ciento
de las mujeres ocupadas en el sector
salud entonces sí y la verdad es que las
jornadas laborales se intensifican hay
riesgos de contagio y verdaderamente
todo esto es un gran desafío para las
mujeres que además tienen encima de su
trabajo normal tienen además sobrecarga
en el trabajo del cuidado absolutamente
alice haciendo que no sea el origen a lo
que hay detrás de esta desigualdad que
es lo que hace según usted que las
mujeres estén en desventaja no frente a
los hombres en términos de participación
en el mercado laboral y porque la
pandemia tiende a incrementar
igualdad
bueno primero que nada porque las
mujeres están en sectores mucho más
precarios y de mayor riesgo en realidad
por ejemplo los sectores de riesgo alto
concentran casi 57 por ciento del empleo
de las mujeres y el 40 por ciento del
empleo de los hombres o sea las mujeres
están en sectores de mayor riesgo verdad
número 1 y número 2 además de eso es que
hay altas tasas de informalidad y muy
baja remuneración y bajos niveles de
calificación las mujeres en general
están en este tipo de trabajos precarios
de baja remuneración de bajo nivel de
calificación y además las mujeres tienen
un bajo porcentaje de está de afiliación
o cotización en sistemas de seguridad y
eso también influye muchísimo fíjate que
además una de cada tres mujeres está es
trabajadora por cuenta propia ocupación
asociada a menor calidad del empleo
trabajan o son propietarias de pequeñas
empresas
en el autofinanciamiento además se
enfrentan mayores barreras para acceder
a recursos financieros formales a
créditos etcétera y por lo tanto esto
representa un gran desafío hoy día en la
reapertura y la sobrevivencia de sus
empresas así es de que ese es un gran
tema y como te mencionaba antes la
industria manufacturera también ha sido
un sector muy clave y ha sufrido mucho
en el sector exportador sobre todo el
cierre de muchas empresas si te digo
sobre todo en centroamérica en donde se
ha visto altamente afectado y sin duda
bueno el sector turismo que es uno de
los sectores también fuertemente
afectados en todos los países de la
región y el empleo de las mujeres se
concentra en microempresas casi el 70%
de las mujeres en este sector están
empleadas en empresas de menos de 5
personas que son las que han cerrado
nosotros calculamos que han cerrado
alrededor de 2.7 millones de mick de
pequeñas y medianas de empresas
microempresas 2.7 de las cuales 2.6 son
empresas muchas de ellas encabezadas por
mujeres así usted recibe referencia a la
baja remuneración que obtienen las
mujeres manejan cifras tienen algún
cálculo por ejemplo en términos
salariales de cuáles es esa brecha entre
hombres y mujeres sí exactamente o sea
lo hemos hecho por sectores y en este
momento tenemos información muy
detallada del sector salud que es el que
te comentaba un poco antes pero también
hemos hecho esta evaluación en otros
sectores productivos lo estamos haciendo
el sector por sector porque no cabe duda
que hay sectores en donde la brecha es
mayor en el sector salud es de 23.7 en
promedio en todos los sectores es
alrededor de 30 por ciento entonces esto
eso es muy muy muy preocupante porque
ahí debería de haber mayor fiscalización
de parte de las autoridades para
garantizar que hubiera realmente una un
equilibrio y una equidad en materia de
de salarios el otro gran tema que
quisiera abordar aquí es el uso de las
plataformas digitales eso para las
mujeres ha sido un gran tema
nosotros en la américa latina y el
caribe tenemos 40 millones de hogares no
conectados a internet y en este sentido
muchas de estos hogares verdad no están
conectados porque no tienen los
suficientes ingresos para tener acceso a
internet y para tener acceso a
equipamiento y ahí vemos que hay una
desventaja muy grande de las mujeres
porque la proporción de mujeres sin
ingresos propios verdad es muy alta es
de 39 por ciento de mujeres en edad de
trabajar que no tienen ingresos propios
y por lo tanto si quisieran acceder en
algunos de ellos a la economía digital
les es imposible así es de que además de
diferencias de ingresos verdad vemos que
las características de los mercados
laborales realmente vemos que hay
otra gran desventaja para las mujeres es
que muchos de sus empleos son imposibles
de hacerse por la vía de teletrabajo en
el sector uno de los sectores más
afectados en el área de laboral fue el
empleo doméstico remunerado que está
fundamentalmente representado por
mujeres y ahí tenemos que son
trabajadoras domésticas remuneradas son
mujeres la mayoría de ellos y la verdad
que han reducido su capacidad de empleo
y la otra es que en muchos casos se han
quedado sin contratos de trabajo no
tienen derechos y creo que ese es un
gran tema del cual tenemos que abordar
pero si 30 por ciento sería la cifra que
te daría de la brecha salarial entre
hombres y mujeres en la región y 30
segundos no quedan nada más de
entrevista que cree usted que pueden
hacer los gobiernos para mejorar esta
situación
bueno sin duda creo que hay muchas cosas
que pueden hacer los gobiernos y tenemos
ejemplos muy buenos por ejemplo de costa
rica- los servicios de cuidado infantil
continuaron abiertos en la emergencia en
mexico continuaron funcionando las
guarderías las estancias es decir
liderando el tiempo de las mujeres para
poder para que pudieran participar en el
mercado laboral pero en la mayoría de
los casos la sobrecarga de cuidados ha
sido muy alta y por lo tanto se tiene
que ir hacia una sociedad a una economía
del cuidado por otro lado también
algunos países han ampliado líneas de
financiamiento dirigidas a mujeres creo
que la otra cosa que pueden hacer los
gobiernos es incorporar a inclusión
digital total para las mujeres hemos
calculado que esto podría costar 1 por
ciento del pib la inclusión digital este
universal en donde todas las mujeres
pudieran ser incluidas alicia bárcena
secretaria ejecutiva de la cepal
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24
muchas gracias a usted un placer como
siempre ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]